you just worked on this film collateral
beauty worked with the great Helen
Mirren many people regard her as one of
the the finest actors alive today what
was that like did you like working with
her I mean she was on my bucket list for
a lot of reasons you know I mean I I had
a I you know when we were kids I love
when I don't have to say any big in your
own hole right here she was I mean
probably one of my first erotic cakes
you know experiences in the world was as
a kid watching Excalibur on HBO you know
you in the thing and Helen you know
going around I'm in Woody Allen you know
get abroad I go you remember her with
Bert you know going around Merlin saying
like her novel yeah yeah yeah it burned
itself into my brain and years later
after I made the first movie I made was
primal fear and I and I was in LA and I
had a few weeks afterward and I had
nowhere to stay and I ended up I
actually ended up staying in a guest
house on on Helen Mirren and her husband
Taylor Hackford is property and Taylor
was away and I met I was 26 and I met
Helen and she said I'll come over for
tea and I thought it's this it's gonna
happen
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's code come over for tea and I I
thought you know and she Helen was known
for you know she many great young actors
had had in we're in her past and I
thought I'm about to join a long
succession of great things and and
nothing happened yeah
not nothing at all did you make a move
at all or no oh wait I was you know I
just were you clutching that hat by any
chance yes I start I started doing the
Sammy bagel voice yeah I was the end
that was the end of it yeah you also
worked but but but in joking aside Jim
she is one of like the legends and and
finally getting to do this film with her
was um was incredibly great but even
better was getting there and finding
that you know after 40 years or more as
it one of the great actresses in in our
industry she she's she's like it's like
she's doing her first film she's so
funny and enthusiastic and loves the
work unpretentious oh my god he's a is
the queen she's yeah really really it
was it was a rare treat
you